how long have you and and mr jerry
o'connell been together we've been
together uh almost 10 years married for
six i've been married six years yes okay
i want to bring something up one of our
staffers backstage because you have to
fill out a few forms and things when you
get here and noticed they saw your
driver's license and it still says
rebecca romain stamos yeah on it yeah
and what's going on on top of that my
children start asking questions soon
have you not you have not changed i am
so lazy i won't go down to the dmv and
stand in line and get that change can
you believe that if you went down
dressed like that you would go right to
the head of the house i think so you
don't think so
i really don't no i uh and it's funny
because i actually
a few years ago jerry uh and i flew up
to visit my mother in the in the bay
area and for some reason he bought
tickets at 6 00 a.m a 6 a.m flight who
does why did he do that for no reason
they were the cheapest ones you know
sure they were the cheapest he is i've
talked to him a lot of times he is a
very notorious cheapskate yes so he he
makes you the beautiful
rebecca romain stamos o'connell jones he
makes you
i'm just throwing names in there he
makes you um work at this point he makes
you fly at six in the morning so we're
running through the airport and um over
the pa system we're late for the flight
obviously it's a six a.m flight on a
saturday morning uh they're going mr
jerry o'connell and miss rebecca romain
stamos as loud over and over and over
again and i'm getting we're racing for
our flight and i'm so furious hearing
this over this pa system and i turn to
jerry and i go this is all your fault
that's the wife's job at that point this
is all you're doing uh